le cateau le pratique vraiment de suivre
peut-être dans les dynamiques non c'est
au dessus
dans le canal annonce parue tu veux
qu'on essaie d'aller voir passer assez
joli avec le vert pétant dans le tribal
kat canon ricoh pas joli sur le pillage
pour les passer pour un rigolo local ya
des bleus partout turquie accueille ou
mario matt et comme on gagne on voudrait
qu'après le calaisis partir d'os casino
local et nous on sait pas c'est pas ça
des fois ça vous parle contre la morale
tout court
ok c'est bon taux de croissance
c'est le premier recteur l'époque cela
on continue on continue ok go jeu
witi jeu plus bas les plus bas
trop même si bas par le yes hockey par
là c'est tout a ajouté l'expert
peut-être plus téléobjectif ça peut être
intéressant aurait pas non non je savais
40 ça me semble pas mal la vitesse est
pas trop non équivoque ont facilement
été pour changer de cadre un petit peu
un moment je vais essayer de tailler
encore un peu plus les vidéos regardées
josé de costa ouais ok et coupé le
tournoi hockey
mais c'est super beau ça
de lévis courbe ah bon je veux leur
faire une feinte celui là avec le fond
alors lapin au début après peut le
refaire avec le bec avec sa barre ouais
ce que ferme
il ya les arbres rouge au fond
bye
voilà on se paye pas
ouais
regarde
vite bon à savoir
alors qu'on arrête dessus parce que là
en latéral
ouais on à paris c'est ça la terreur
quoi pourrait presque faire à l'envers
mais très lent je ne vois pas ils sont à
droite
ah ouais donc cessé avant la course
devant oui mais ça s'est super bien
c'est very good à droite là vous allez
voir comment on pourrait faire ça bien
là les mairies pas bien prendre dans ses
poches et oui les hérons d'être
rapidement être encore très rigolo
on est à vingt deux ans
il ya du soleil arrive je coupe
après la lumière tu veux aller voir
tortuguero on essaye de faire leur
entrée à l'intérieur pour tout virus en
remontant la côte